JD works in a glass booth every day
after the show JD eats lunch and I just
I just stop whatever I'm doing this is
my meditative moment I stop whatever I'm
doing and I just watched JD eat and try
to figure out what the [ __ ] he's eating
what was that yesterday there was some
kind of mystery sandwich like a pasta
thing and with the meat and kale almost
a piece of bread it's like birthing oh
that's the thing you know he writes
exactly how he talks yes we were 20 some
vegan restaurant that he told me was
good as a JD do me a favor when you go
there tell me what you had and if it was
good or not cuz I'd go right so he
writes me goes uh I wish I had the note
in front of me goes a great out you
printed up Regis what you had he puts
the word thing he goes I had a pasta
thing he doesn't know ever was like okay
I understand when he's talking he's like
I had a pasta thing and I kept a weird
thing but when you're writing would you
write it you can edit it he doesn't he
doesn't edit anything do you read it or
print it out read it it was pretty good
I got a pasta thing with bolognese pasta
thing and I wrote pasta thing and I go a
pasta thing how about I had pasta a
vegetable thing it was another thing he
had a food thing whatever wife got
Tibetan mama rice bowl you know was good
no but I was just the pasta thing that
caught me off guard
well you would have missed Bullock
neighs if you hadn't helped Bullock
mayonnaise I had like a bowling maze
thing look Nate ball thing marinagre2 I
grow yeah when he writes me remember he
wanted to call his wife a beautiful
creature at it yeah I love you so much
you are a beautiful creature yeah
trying to read it first of all I can't
imagine my life without you I'm crying
because you mean so much to me I want to
make you happy you're so beautiful and
sweet we have so much fun I don't want
that I don't want it to end I hope you
don't still marry me I love you first of
all you scratching that word creature
you don't call your wife a creature okay
and I can understand if you reside
living and maybe it comes out weird but
he had it written down this yeah out of
all the words descriptive words he found
to write down was creature you are a
beautiful creature a beautiful creature
thing I love your vagina thing or your
titty things are nice troll so were you
planning to cry that was the other thing
that he says I'm crying because crying
because I'm a creep I was crying as I
was writing it I'm not sure how this
drunk I'm crying because you're a
gorgeous monster or our troll who lives
under a bridge I am so lucky that you're
such a lovely thing